we always like to end the show with a
gym of inspiration from social media
this is what I'm liking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what was visiting New York City a
complete stranger gave him 200 to see a
Broadway show it's a moment that always
stuck with him cut to 2022 and Claiborne
Elder is now a successful actor in his
own right starring in company on
Broadway and in one of my favorite TV
shows the Gilded Age and thanks to a
little recent Serendipity he's now
helping hundreds of total strangers see
Broadway shows for free we have him on
the line right now watching on NBC4 New
York at three what's up Cleveland
hey how are you thanks for having me oh
my God it's so nice first of all to meet
you I love you um it's great to meet you
but you only set out to give away one
pair of tickets right that's right yeah
it was late in 2021 I got sick with
covet and was out of my Broadway show
for a few weeks and when I came back I
wanted to do something to celebrate you
know coming back so I posted on
Instagram that I was giving away two
tickets to anyone who couldn't afford
them and you know I'd never reconnected
with the man who gave me the tickets or
the money for the tickets years ago but
I kind of wanted to honor his kindness
in some way and pay it forward
and um pretty immediately things blew up
and somebody leaked my venmo account and
people started sending me money to buy
more tickets from all over the place
some people sent me a thousand dollars
some people sent me two dollars they
just sent whatever they could and
instead of giving away two tickets I
gave away 68 tickets to that first
performance and what I'm now calling
city of strangers
that's so that's so cool so how big is
city of strangers now
1600 tickets valued at over twenty five
thousand dollars
and when I look back at that man who
gave me the money all those years ago
his kindness really made me a Kinder
person and that's the kind of thing I'm
hoping to inspire in some way for people
and this is really crazy but um
thank you and this is really crazy but
he uh I posted it and it went viral and
because of that somebody saw that
picture and recognized him and
reconnected us so I got to reach out to
him and tell him what he did for me 15
years ago and now we're friends and we
text all the time and we just sort of
knew that we were supposed to be in each
other's lives that is so cool man you're
changing so many lives and inspiring so
many people because I remember I was a
sophomore on a scholarship with a choir
program I wouldn't have been able to
afford it because people paid the money
I was able to go and see the shows with
everybody from Texas and seeing Les Mis
is a sophomore in high school like
changed my life it was so beautiful and
I was like I want to be on stage and it
was like the big thing that drove me to
that so you're helping inspire so many
future actors and singers out there so
that's really cool thank you so much
claimer I'm liking your posts right now
all right
all right so that's not all our season
long partner pilot pin makers of G2 the
go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to honor truly Unstoppable people
and kind people just like you so they're
going to be riding city of strangers a
check for a thousand dollars
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]